Perhaps, you were surprised by the last problem that you worked with Sarah. In
that problem, an object was shared with two variables. Let's have a closer look
at what happens in that case. Here, we have an object that's stored in a
variable. Now, it's important not to confuse the object which I've drawn here
with the variable. In Java, an object variable does not actually contain the
object. Instead, it contains information on how to find the object, it contains
the location of the object. We draw that location with an arrow and we call it
a reference. Now, suppose we make a second variable and copy the first one into
the second. In that case, we simply copy this reference into this variable. As
you can see now, both the variable box and the variable box2 refer to the same
object. Now, suppose we call a mutator on one of the variables. As you can see,
the object has changed. And that change is observable both through the variable
box and through the variable box2. That's just how object variables work in
Java. And it's good to know, because you can then explain how objects work when
they're copied. Sarah will practice that with you with another problem.